okay know in the comments if you know
where my keys are I am locked out of my
apartment and my landlord said I cannot
sleep in the hallway again and cut great
job guys
I missed most of the show because
there's free pizza in the conference
room oh yeah Ryan I can only assume that
your knees were too pointy again so
smooth them out somehow that's it I mean
yeah but you better hurry you know how
people get around here when this free
pizza
[Music]
oh my god I'm telling HR Sparkle lunch
bitch
Oh Nate I'm the boss now also dude
culturally insensitive costume
Oh
[Music]
there is the conference room
you know all that's left is Veggie Oh
gross never lines anybody main tank tank
he loves that
[Music]
you